the apollo 11 moon landing was one of
the boldest milestones in human history
yet it almost didn't happen on july 20
1969 three minutes before neil armstrong
in buzz aldrin stepped foot on the lunar
surface
something went wrong the computer set
off alarms warning of an emergency error
codes popped up on screen
nasa faced a tough decision should they
continue or cancel the mission had the
agency decided to abort it would have
been a crushing blow for nasa
heartbreaking for the nation and would
have created a window of opportunity for
the russians to get to the moon first in
the end the astronauts landed safely
thanks to a young brilliant software
engineer
margaret hamilton developed nasa's
in-flight software for apollo she spent
her entire career focused on
anticipating problems and solving them
which saved the moon landing her pension
for detecting errors came from an
unexpected place after an incident
involving her young daughter
hamilton was born 33 years earlier on
august 17 1936 in the small town of
paulie indiana she earned a degree in
mathematics with a minor in philosophy
from earlin college she taught math at
high school for a year before following
her husband to cambridge massachusetts
where he attended harvard law school to
support her husband's studies she took a
job at mit writing software that could
predict the weather
software engineering was not yet a field
people didn't go to school to learn how
to program hamilton taught herself she
later wrote software to detect enemy
aircraft for the military and then
planned to get a phd in abstract
mathematics but one day her husband
noticed a newspaper ad that a lab at mit
was looking for programmers to help take
people to the moon nasa had contracted
that lab to build the onboard flight
software for apollo hamilton jumped at
the opportunity to join the team she was
the first programmer they hired a woman
in a heavily male world hamilton began
writing code for the portable computer
responsible for controlling the
spacecraft the apollo guidance computer
engineered at mit was a technological
marvel given computers back then were
the size of rooms one unit was aboard
the command module colombia that took
astronauts to and from earth the other
was aboard eagle which landed on the
moon at first nasa executives assigned
hamilton low-level tasks since she was
one of the least experienced programmers
her first assignment was to write code
that would kick in if the mission had to
abort the higher-ups were so sure this
wouldn't happen that she named her
program forget it because she didn't
think any of the emergencies she planned
for would ever see the light of day
her software needed to detect unexpected
errors quickly and recover from them in
real time however it was very difficult
to do because the software at the time
could only process jobs in a
predetermined order so she developed
what's called a synchronous programming
this allowed the computer to recognize
error messages and ignore low priority
tasks in favor of more important ones so
even if there were an error the high
priority tasks would continue to be
performed this is a photo of her beside
a stack of printed code that's nearly as
tall as her she had insisted on adding
more code as a safeguard to prevent a
crash from happening after an incident
with her young daughter she brought her
four-year-old daughter to work one day
and lauren played astronaut and started
hitting the keys which crashed the
system during a simulation of a mission
to the moon her daughter had selected a
program that was meant to be used
pre-launch which caused the computer to
lose its navigation data hamilton
thought to herself my god this could
inadvertently happen in a real mission
as she told the guardian and if that
happened the crew could be lost in space
so she asked her bosses for permission
to add more fail saves at first they
refused because it was just more
software to debug and work with plus
they didn't actually think astronauts
would make that mistake but that mistake
happened on the very next mission during
apollo 8 the first manned mission
orbiting the moon experienced astronaut
jim lovell said uh-oh i think i just did
something wrong
he had accidentally pushed the wrong
button which started the pre-launch
program and created havoc hamilton and
her coders spent nine hours
painstakingly troubleshooting the
problem and fortunately managed to send
new navigation data to the spacecraft
guiding the astronauts back home
after that nightmare hamilton's
higher-ups let her put more safeguards
into the software by this time she had
worked her way up from a junior engineer
to lead software design for the apollo
program everyone realized hamilton's
ability to detect errors and recover
from them the team got the greatest
scare during the apollo 11 mission
just as armstrong and aldrin were about
to land on the lunar surface the
computer started flashing error codes
hamilton was standing in the monitoring
room at mit when she saw what was
happening they later discovered that a
radar switch was in the wrong position
and took up processing power overloading
the computer the moon mission was at
risk of being aborted
however
nasa trusted hamilton's system they
believed it was well designed and can
come to the rescue and it did her code
prioritized the most important tasks and
allowed the mission to stay on track yes
indeed they've got the flag up now and
you can see the stars
the software worked perfectly and both
astronauts landed safely on the moon it
was a moment that hit hamilton hard she
recalled saying my god look what
happened we did it it worked it was
exciting
hamilton popularized the term software
engineering at the time software was not
taken as seriously as other disciplines
in engineering
she helped launch an industry that is
now changing human history margaret
hayfield hamilton
in 2017 president barack obama awarded
hamilton the united states highest
civilian award the presidential medal of
freedom
president obama said our astronauts
didn't have much time but thankfully
they had margaret hamilton
it's thanks to curious minds that were
able to venture out into the solar
system if you love learning and want to
invest in yourself by picking up new
skills my sponsor skillshare is the
perfect place to start skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of inspiring classes from video editing
to photography to graphic design you can
find classes that match your interests i
personally found polymatter is making an
animated video class particularly
helpful it gave me great tips on for
example how to choose the right colors
to create the best designs all the
classes are broken down into short
sections there are no ads or tests the
first 1000 people to use my link which
is in the description will get a one
month free trial of skillshare premium
thanks for watching for a news i'm cindy
palm